voici bientôt trois mois que vous menez
une campagne extrêmement active sur le
terrain vous avez sillonné la france
entière le territoire métropolitain mais
aussi les départements et les
territoires d'outre-mer vous avez tenu
de multiples réunions vous avez
rencontré beaucoup de gens comment au
moment où cette campagne s'achève
pratiquement pourriez vous résumer votre
impression générale sur ce que pensent
les français
eh bien j'ai tout nous est d'abord
constaté que
les deux candidats qui étaient déjà
présents en 1974
n'ont su ni convaincre ni entraîner les
français
et j'ai constaté au contraire que ma
candidature que y ait un accord un
soutien le chaque jour plus important
et vous avez une explication à ce double
mouvement l'un de monter et l'autre de
stagnation et je crois que cela tient au
fait que les français ressentent
actuellement une espèce de découragement
de malaise ils n'ont pas été mobilisés
et ce découragement et ce malaise
viennent je crois du fait qu'il faut
aujourd'hui les gouvernés autrement
c'est-à-dire en leur donnant à la fois
plus de responsabilités plus de liberté
mais aussi en leur donnant le sentiment
que leurs affaires intérieures et
extérieures
sont traités avec plus de fermeté je
crois que c'est sale vous ne croyez pas
que la raison essentielle du ce malaise
prenons le mot c'est quand même quelque
chose de beaucoup plus concret le
chômage par exemple qui touche toutes
les familles oui naturellement le
chômage c'est d'ailleurs le point
central de toute la politique que je
propose aux français et qui consiste à
lutter contre le chômage a augmenté la
production mais au delà de ce problème
il y en a un autre qui et comment dirais
je
ressentis confusément et qu'ils aient le
sentiment qu'on les français d'une
certaine inutilité si j'ose dire c'est à
dire le sentiment que leurs problèmes
quotidiens ne sont pas compris que leurs
suggestions ne sont pas entendus qu'il
n'y a pas de dialogue
entre eux et les pouvoirs publics ceux
qui sont responsables des affaires de la
nation qu'il n'ya pas en un mot de
concertation et comment est-ce que cela
se passerait concrètement si vous étiez
comment vous y prendriez vous pour faire
comprendre aux français qu'ils sont pris
en considération encore c'est un peu ça
votre objectif
écoutez je crois que c'est d'abord et
avant tout une question d'état d'esprit
si vous me permettez je reprendrai un
exemple qui était celui de mon
expérience comme ministre de
l'agriculture je n'ai jamais à cette
époque pris une seule décision qui n'ait
été au préalable
prise en accord avec l'ensemble des
représentants des organisations
agricoles alors naturellement ça demande
du temps ça demande un effort de
compréhension mutuelle ce n'est pas
simplement un dialogue où chacun
s'exprime et où ensuite l'état décide
c'est véritablement
l'exigence d'une meilleure compréhension
mutuelle est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
catégories sociales qui seraient
concernées par cette politique de
concertation à donner mais tout bien
entendu prenons quelques exemples vous
avez aujourd'hui
les les cadres je veux dire l'ensemble
du personnel dans le cadre mans c'est à
dire cadres et agents de maîtrise qui
savent qu'ils sont l'ossature même de la
nation qu'ils sont responsables de son
avenir de son activité et qui ont le
sentiment à la fois d'être mal à l'aise
dans leur entreprise malgré bien sûr des
exceptions mais surtout de ne pas être
considéré compris entendu de ne pas
pouvoir dialoguer normalement avec les
pouvoirs publics sur des problèmes qui
sont à l'évidence même de leurs
compétences et de leurs responsabilités
vous avez les professions libérales
on explique aujourd'hui en permanence
que nous sommes pour une société de
liberté d'initiative de responsabilité
et on laisse petit à petit marginaliser
les professions libérales on ne leur
donne pas la faculté de s'épanouir au
contraire on les
en permanence on fait en sorte qu'elle
ne soit pas libres de leurs mouvements
il faut là aussi avoir un véritable
dialogue avec elle je condamne un
dernier exemple qui sont les
fonctionnaires le problème des
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
d'en créer davantage le problème c'est
de leur donner plus de sens des
responsabilités
le convaincre qu'ils sont au service de
la nation et leur donnait bien entendu à
statut une considération qui leur
revient prenez par exemple les
instituteurs il est extraordinaire que
ce corps qui a tant fait pour le pays
qui sous la troisième république
notamment est encore sous la ivème a
forgé en quelque sorte la république
aujourd'hui se sentent aussi mal à
l'aise et que le dialogue entre eux et
les pouvoirs publics soit devenu une
sorte de dialogue de sourds il faut
aujourd'hui que l'on se comprenne mieux
je ne dis pas qu'il faut leur donner
satisfaction surtout ce n'est pas le
problème mais il faut se comprendre
mieux et donc discuter davantage prendre
en considération les uns et les autres
les problèmes et les suggestions de
chacun vous définissez ainsi une sorte
de manière de gouverner différente de ce
qui se pratique à l'heure actuelle mais
je me demande si dans cette impression
de malaise que vous avez ressenti il n'y
a pas quelque chose dont on parle moins
souvent mais qui est une espèce
d'inquiétude sourde des françaises et
des français devant la façon dont les
affaires de la france sont conduits à
l'extérieur dont la france contribue
aujourd'hui au développement de la paix
dans le monde
oui encore que les français n'ont jamais
pris exactement conscience
des conséquences de la politique
étrangère sur leur vie quotidienne
mais aujourd'hui ils se rendent compte
davantage de cette importance
il faut dans une politique étrangère une
très grande fermeté il la faut d'abord
pour défendre les intérêts de notre pays
on ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui par
exemple que à bruxelles au sein de la
communauté européenne la france est
suffisamment d'autorité et de vaud et
pour défendre les intérêts de nos
agriculteurs de nos marins pêcheurs de
nos sidérurgiste de nos travailleurs de
l'industrie du textile ou d'autres c'est
sans doute un domaine la politique
étrangère où il est facile on le voit
ces temps-ci de critiquer il est plus
difficile de proposer et quelles
seraient les fondements d'une politique
étrangère que vous pourriez venez si
vous étiez
bien se fonde non je crois sont simples
il ya d'abord le fait qu'il faut
toujours avoir le même langage quel que
soit l'interlocuteur auquel on s'adresse
il faut ensuite être profondément
convaincu que lorsque les intérêts de la
france et des français sont en jeu le
compromis ou la concession n'est pas
acceptable il faut enfin savoir que la
france a traditionnellement un message à
apporter au monde et à ses délires une
responsabilité à l'égard des autres
nations et que ce message c'est la
défense intransigeante des droits de
l'homme des droits des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes et sur ces domaines
la france ne doit pas accepter de
concessions
l'un des moyens de cette politique
étrangère
particulièrement résolu et active c'est
la présence des français à l'étranger
est également la présence de la france
sous une forme qui est très importante
qui était celle de sa longue oui c'est
exact la france a le privilège d'être
présente au monde un peu partout d'abord
géographiquement par ces départements
d'outre-mer par ses territoires
d'outre-mer qui font qu'elle n'est pas
un pays comme les autres replié sur son
hexagone d'où l'importance de ces
régions la france ensuite à beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes auxquelles je
tiens particulièrement aujourd'hui à
rendre hommage et qui la représente sur
le plan économique social culturel un
peu partout dans le monde la france a
cette chance extraordinaire
d'avoir une langue et une culture
internationale et d'ailleurs elle ne
défend pas ses sept langues et cette
culture il faut avoir une politique
beaucoup plus dynamique de défense de la
langue française dans le monde et puis
il ya enfin les problèmes qu'il ne faut
pas oublier qu'ils sont liés à sa
défense on en parle assez peu dans cette
campagne électorale ce que vous pourriez
nous préciser un peu quels sont les
grands axes de votre politique de
défense y est la dissuasion d'abord bien
entendu
et la défense d'abord est liée à la
politique étrangère une politique
étrangère qui veut sauvegarder la paix
doit être une politique de fermeté
lorsque les pays occidentaux ont marqué
leur fermeté la détente s'est développée
et la paix s'est affirmée
lorsqu au contraire comme l'a dénoncé il
y a trois ou quatre ans monsieur
soljenitsyne les pays occidentaux ont
voulu discuter concédé compromettre
alors 1 les russes puisque c'est d'eux
qu'il s'agit du relm en ont pris un
certain nombre d'initiatives pour
pousser leur avantage et ça remette en
cause à la fois la détente et la paix on
le voit bien aujourd'hui il faut donc
plus de fermeté et cette fermeté
s'appuient notamment sur l'existence
d'une défense nationale qui soit
véritablement efficace pour l'efficacité
aujourd'hui et plus personne ne le
conteste c'est la défense nucléaire et
notamment la composante de notre défense
nucléaire qui est la moins vulnérables
c'est-à-dire celles qui se trouvent sous
les mers nos sous marins nucléaires
c'est pourquoi je propose d'augmenter
notre effort en ce qui concerne les sous
marins nucléaires il faut pouvoir
montrer sa force pour ne pas avoir à
s'en servir
ça aussi c'est le service d'une
politique de paix dans cet effort de
défense vous parlez beaucoup du
nucléaire il ya aussi une autre
composante car la france a des voies
d'approvisionnement
protéger
vis-à-vis de l'étranger elle a besoin
d'une force d'intervention est ce qu'il
n'ya pas là aussi quelques problèmes à
l'heure actuelle sur comment on pourrait
évoquer l actuellement tous ces
problèmes non seulement elle a des voies
d'approvisionnement à protéger les ailes
à des accords oui mais aussi est là les
accords avec un certain nombre de pays
je pense en particulier avec l'afrique
qui sont des accords de défense et
qu'elle doit être en état de respecter
et cela suppose que ces forces
d'intervention soit demain doté de ce
qui leur manque c'est à dire des moyens
matériels et notamment des moyens de
transport qui lui sont indispensables
alors monsieur chirac devant un monde
aussi dangereux aussi compliqué devant
une tâche sur aussi lourde que celle qui
vous attend si vous êtes élu est ce que
vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste
je suis optimiste
je le suis d'abord parce que c'est dans
ma nature
je le suis ensuite parce que lorsqu'on
veut gouverner un pays on n'a pas le
droit d'être pessimiste et je le suis
enfin parce que j'ai profondément
confiance dans la capacité de la france
qui est un grand pays qui n'est pas un
bourg sans dans le monde a surmonté ses
problèmes et qui demain comme hier sera
un grand pays en tous les cas pour ma
part je ferai en sorte si je suis élu
que les français souhaitent à la fois
fiers et heureux d'être français